back golfing dining large events chimera
golf in henderson is a wonderful
destination and thank you to cisco for
sponsoring this segment and here to tell
us more is jeff allen he's the director
of food and beverage and their executive
chef juan is here with us as well good
morning good afternoon gentlemen thank
you for having us before we get into
this food that you brought and what a
spread you have let's talk about the
golf course tell me more about the
actual course itself sure an 18-hole
championship golf course a lot of great
views from our tee boxes of the
surrounding area in las vegas
framed by the mountains uh very playable
golf course for all levels of golfers um
do you want to talk about the slice 19
yeah absolutely well yeah because
actually devon when our photographer
said he's got there many times
it's a fantastic course and when you're
done golfing you want to eat some food
slice 19. chef one what's some of the
food that you guys offer yeah so i'm
excited to be here thank you for having
us we just changed into a new menu and
everything about this menu
i was
looking to make sure i can get nothing
but the freshest at a funko so
everything that you see here
most of it is cisco acquired through
cisco but real fast here i have a fall
salad that resembles the foliage steak
salad cocktail camaron
poke ball
this is our our pastrami burger
everything about his burgers awesome now
i've been a couple of uh clubhouses and
stuff and i don't see this kind of food
this is five-star restaurant food is
what we're looking at good and anyone
can show up right anyone can make
anything like this
we're in the uh tuscany neighborhood but
it's a uh open to the public uh
breakfast lunch and dinner seven a.m to
nine pm every day devin can you get a
shot on the other on the counter of that
shrimp cocktail i have not seen shrimp
cocktail that big before that is shrimp
on steroids right now that's
unbelievable that is unbelievable okay
now you got your you got the pan here i
feel the warm pan what did you make for
us today so what i did this is an item
that we serve on our taco tuesday which
is extremely popular we slowly cooked
the barbacoa traditional traditionally
and we pants here the barbacoa tacos and
accompanied with a banana salsa homemade
guacamole and a chunky mild salsa
awesomeness on a plate that's the great
way to summer awesomeness and a plate i
wish you guys could smell the studio
right now because the smell and the
aroma of these tacos is just
unbelievable can you please pass me that
plate chef absolutely i gotta give it a
shot do you guys do a trivia night on
tuesday nights too we do trevor night
correct from uh 5 to 8 p.m is actually
taco tuesday and inside of that is 7 8
is the trivia which is very popular so
you have to get there early for that we
fill up pretty quick from that now also
too the holidays are coming up if
someone's watching and they want to have
a company party there how many people
can you guys accommodate we accommodate
up to 175 in our pavilion
we can do we do a lot of weddings we do
banquets all type of events and holiday
parties as you mentioned that is awesome
gentlemen thank you so much for joining
us i got to give it a bite here hold on
a second
oh my gosh
chef try the sauce yeah
you guys seriously
this is insane well thank you so much we
appreciate it
thank you to cisco for sponsoring this
event uh you guys are fantastic chimera
golf club is located in henderson call
them at
702-951-1500 this is so good find them
online at chimeragolfclub.com
rocky over to you you're right over
there oh my gosh